The answer is it will fail for some data sets.
If the user inputs a bunch of numbers that are all
negative, none of these will ever be greater than 0.
So largest will just stay 0 the whole time even though
there's no number as large as 0 in the data
set. Having a 0 in the data set is okay. If
the data set was negative 2, negative 3, 0, 4,
eventually we would find the 4, and that would be larger
than 0. We can even take away the 4.
If the data set was just negative 2, negative 3,
and 0, this code would find that the largest
number is 0, which is true in this case. So
having a 0 in the data set doesn't affect
whether this code works or not. We know it won't
work because of the example that I gave before. And
this will work fine even if there's only one input.